devyn let's take another hypothetical
someone comes to you with a maybe
$100,000 budget and they ask you and
your partner Larry to come and work but
they can't pay you outright they're
gonna pay you once they get distribution
sort of in the back end sure so how do
you handle this first I will read the
script and it's a script well very sorry
so if someone comes to me with a hundred
thousand dollar script and they don't
want to pay and they they feel like they
can't afford to pay my team up or Larry
Knight up front but they won't give us
points on the back end then I will say
let's do a co-production deal so I know
it's 50/50 and then anything divide
anything any other points given out to
anybody else we split that evenly so
what if so we'll end up doing it like
that but again it's based on if the
script is good and then I'll say let me
do a budget for it and if I find room in
the budget even for two thousand dollars
then we we deal with it that way the
actually the movie we're filming now is
a little bit more that but we are taking
everything on the back end now ten years
ago five six eight six years ago I
wouldn't have been in that position to
do that I said no like I'm gonna work
like I have to take guys like a paycheck
on it but because we're so busy now I
can I can look at a project and go this
is really good project I believe in it
yeah let's list the sprocket you know
and then make sure the script matches
what we can afford and get it done and
we when we do that you know we um and
pace it it depends on the people
involved really but you know we just
like to make really cool content and be
proud of it and I would tell someone
like if you have a hundred thousand
dollars most people like to do just like
big an ensemble cast as I say no don't
do that
put 10,000 or 15,000 towards or 20,000
tours like a name actor that will sell
your movie and then everyone else pay
them the regular sag rate of 126 for the
day but get really good actors
well our people will do it they'll put a
bunch of healed c-level actors in the
movie that's not gonna sell you know AFM
you see Steve is in Gaul everywhere and
we're like wow the hell Steven Seagal in
all these movies like I mean I'm a
martial artist I like Eileen I grew up a
fan of his but it's like they're like he
still sells overseas like he's making
millions of dollars still sounding
international yeah you kick Steven 15
grand for like a week's worth of work
he'll sell your movie and take the other
115 put it all tours proof you know so
there's worries a dupe still yummy its
but then it's a question yeah we we we
do do that based on the project but I
always find a little bit of money
somewhere Devon how much are you
involved in the distribution of the film
after it's me my distribution
involvement is based on the project so
if it's if I'm just lying producing
depends on the team sometimes they're
like we already have distribution we
have people that we always work with
great fantastic and then it's other
projects they're like yeah I mean you
know let's set up some meetings with
your people with set up meetings with my
people and let's just see who gives us
the best deal most of the most though
it's a project a project basis but I'm
fully involved in and on our projects
and know all about it so that's always a
good thing
you